Germans are content and by big margins
three out of four say they're doing well
financially that's one reason Chancellor
Angela Merkel's government is getting
high marks if injured so I'm very
satisfied we have a good Chancellor
who's viewed highly in Europe and the
world she's done a good job tackling the
crisis and has kept unemployment low
need a guy once get sick we're doing
well we have everything we have peace
what more could we want our German
satisfied with the work of their
government fifty-two percent of them say
yes forty-seven percent of them say
they're not satisfied d quality I don't
like the coalition in what way the
cousin in fighting the flip-flopping and
zigzagging zigzag awesome yes I'm o on
the issue of eavesdropping the emails
the NSA scandal I find the government's
performance they're totally
unsatisfactory young for details will be
fitting that she had a show there are
always aries you can criticize no one's
perfect epic whether Germans will choose
to make Angela Merkel Chancellor again
won't be decided until sep tember the
22nd
you